hey guys glad to have you back and
looking forward to making another video
today we'll be talking about geospatial
indexes now this is one of those things
where for some reason it comes up in the
systems design interview a lot and
frankly I have no idea why because it's
super Niche and most people are probably
never going to use these in their career
but I've been asked about it multiple
times at this point so uh I guess we
just have to learn it and uh get the
hacky way out and do that so let's get
into the video and uh I'll start
explaining things all right so what does
something like a geospatial index allow
us to solve what type of problems are we
going to have to bring this up for well
the main ones that I'm thinking of here
things like Yelp Uber Tinder Etc
basically the main problem that this
type of database or this type of index
is going to solve for us is finding all
the points within some distance so if
you've got a cartisian plane and you're
over here and you've got a bunch of
points scattered around you it's going
to help find that close radius of points
so let's go ahead and look at an example
problem because that is probably going
to make this most concrete and then you
you'll see why the need for specialized
kind of Technology arises here so one
thing that most men have heard if there
somewhat online is that there are lots
of singles in their area just waiting to
hang out with them but let's see can we
verify how true this is let's imagine
that all of the ladies in our radius are
plotted on a cartisian plane as shown
below I've got a 2d plane and then
you're over here in this case I'm right
over here at 2 comma 2 so that's our x
coordinate is two and then our
y-coordinate is also two so let's
imagine that we tried to use a
traditional database in order to solve
this problem and a traditional database
index so let's imagine that we indexed
all of our points by their x coordinate
so we would start from the left side we
would go towards our right side and then
yeah that's uh pretty simple enough
basically then what would happen is that
you know as you can see the Jordan point
is over here in the index and if we
wanted to find all of the closest points
in the graph we would probably start by
looking at all the points with the
closest x value which in this case is
going to be these guys over here which
on the map is this so you can see that
that is going to get us our closest
points from the X distance but at the
same time assuming that our map is
actually big enough we might have points
way out here in the distance which are
Super far away and if you're actually
looking at our graph you can see we've
got 3 comma 1 over here which is still
closer to me but because it's not
perfectly aligned with my x coordinate I
probably wouldn't have even checked that
so indexing by the x coordinate isn't
going to work what about indexing by the
y-coordinate well you would probably
have a similar phenomenon where what
would end up happening is because my
y-coordinate is at 0 2 we would end up
looking for all of the things with a y
coordinate of two it would return all of
these results and yet again we would
look first at these two before again
looking at three comma 1 which is
actually the closer point and so as you
can see it's clear that for something
like a two-dimensional coordinate plane
using a single dimensional index value
isn't going to help us really filter
down our points to get the closest one
especially as the Earth that you're
considering and the number of points
that you're considering becomes bigger
and bigger so what can we actually do
well basically we are going to use a
technology called geohashes or quad
trees and so they're not entirely the
same but the idea behind the two of them
is similar what I'm going to be showing
in this video is technically not the
same as either of them it's my own
little stupid representation but it
pretty much encapsulates the idea of the
goash and the quad tree and so the point
is that we're taking our 2D coordinate
plane we're taking every single point
which has two coordinates and we're
basically going to compress them down
into one single point known as a geohash
so how do we actually go ahead and do
this let's imagine that you know we've
got our coordinate plane right here as
you can see we've got our axes drawn out
and then every single area of the
coordinate plane we break it into a box
and so first I start by lab in the
outermost quadrants so the first
quadrant is a the second quadrant is B
the third quadrant is C and the fourth
quadrant is D now I'm just for the sake
of uh keeping this simple we're going to
dive into breaking down the C quadrant a
little bit more I'm going to break that
down into four pieces as you can see
we've got the following lines right here
and basically what's going to happen
once I break that down is that we now
have a CA a CB a cc and a CD and then we
can even go further than that in fact
let's break down CB to show what's going
to happen so let's going to be this box
over here and as you can see we've
broken it into a CBA a CBB a CBC and a
CBD so now imagine we've got this one
point over here let's say that I was
searching for all of the points within
box
CBA in this case what we would basically
do is know that every single point
within a box is going to be prefixed by
the string name of that box so
regardless of you know we breaking CBA
down anymore and let's say this was box
CBD uh CB a d the point is we know that
any point in this area start with the
string CBA and so that's super important
to us because it means that if we want
to find all of the points that are
within a certain box all we have to do
is search for all of the points that
have that prefix and if our points are
ordered in our database that basically
means that we're searching for all the
points where the string name is between
CBA and CBB because we can
lexicographically sort them and then we
would go ahead and run that search and
of course like a normal database index
if all of our points are sorted right so
if our points are sorted by the geohash
then that's just a binary search and
I'll show a more concrete example of
this in a second so yeah let's do this
example so imagine that I'm right over
here and I want to find all the points
that are near me as you can see they're
dots on the graph which is good and then
let's imagine as well that because these
geohashes are kind of predefined someone
has already made these we know the set
distance of every size of the box so we
know for example that as you can see uh
this is box BCB that I'm in right here
and we know that if a box is three
letters that means it's equal to 1 mile
by one mile two letters for example is
equal to 2x two so 2 miles by 2 miles
one letter is equal to 4 miles by 4
miles so let's say we wanted to find
basically everyone within one mile of me
and I know that I'm at coordinate 1.7
comma 1.7 I can get that from the GPS on
my phone for example so the first thing
that we're going to do is once I have
1.7 1.7 I'm going to f find what box
that I'm in so for starters I know I'm
in box B right because when we have our
like initial geohash of the world we
have some geohash Library we can start
by saying all right let's Loop through
all of the single letter boxes so let's
Loop through a b c and d and we know the
coordinate bounds of each of these so
for example B is from you know this area
right here it's between 0a 0 0a 4 uh or
rather uh yeah 0 comma Sorry 4 comma 0 0
comma 4 and then 4 comma 4 and so since
I'm 1.7 1.7 I know hey I'm in box B and
then we would do the same thing from
there ba a BC uh oh my God I don't know
letters BB BC and BD and then we would
say which one of these am I in oh
clearly I'm in BC because I know that BC
is basically the one from 0 comma 0 it's
this box right here and so I know I'm in
there and then finally I can say oh now
I know I'm in
BCB okay So eventually I figure out the
fact that I'm in BCB but I also know
that compared to the coordinate
boundaries of Point BCB
I'm in the very top right corner and so
it's possible that my one mile radius
might stretch out into the other
neighboring boxes so just due to the way
that our um geohashes are laid out we
can actually easily figure out that the
boxes that are next to mine are going to
be first of all B A over here because
our radius might stretch into it and
also in addition to that we have uh
let's see
BDA so our radius is in there as well
and so now we know that we need to
search for all of the points in those
three boxes and then once we have them
we can filter that down a little bit and
make sure that all of the points that we
get back are within one mile so like I
said in Step six we take all the points
and then calculate whether they're
actually within a mile and then we
return the result so how would we go
ahead and calculate whether we're
actually within a mile well we could
just use our Pythagorean theorem from
our geometry class back in 8th grade
which is that when you have a
triangle we know that A2 + B2 = c^2
so if we know the distance between the X
and the y-coordinate we can quickly find
the actual distance between them in
terms of a radius this is a little bit
different for latitude and longitude I
believe but it's kind of the same
premise so again how would this actually
look on a database well as you can see
we've got all of our geohashes over here
they're
sorted by
goash so this is where Jordan is so
that's where we're starting that's where
we're looking for the nearest points and
keep in mind if you recall from step
five over here I have three ranges that
I need to be able to search in my
database and so I've outlined those for
myself just so I didn't have to go back
and forth they're here here and here and
these are three independent log n
searches where n is the number of points
in the database because they're all
binary searches the points are all next
to one another in the database which is
why this is so fast and then once we
have them you know we now have like five
possible possible candidate
points and then what do we do we use the
Pythagorean theorem to actually
determine whether they're in one mile of
1.7 1.7 so I would be looking at this
column once I find them in the actual
geohash
area cool so hopefully that makes sense
let's get to a quick tangent which is
actually going to be called GEOS
sharding because again the whole point
of this channel is that we're working
with distributed systems typically there
is too much data to actually just fit it
all on one computer and as a result of
that we have to be smart about how we
want to partition our results of course
our entire prerogative here is to keep
data that is close to one another in 2D
space close to one another on disk and
we are going to be keeping the same uh
principle with GEOS sharding generally
speaking if you have really population
dense areas here's my super shitty
drawing of the US basically
versus super sparse
areas perhaps even if one bounding box
is bigger or smaller than the other they
can be on the same node so for example
over here we can throw New York City on
its own Shard if you're familiar with
the map of the US maybe some of you are
less so because you're not from here and
then for example you know over here
we've got like Colorado Oklahoma Wyoming
all these states that are kind of just
Fly Over States have a lot less people
we can throw this on their own shard
and so by being smart about how many
points are in there versus kind of the
range that it's going to be putting on a
given computer when we're partitioning
we can basically go ahead and balance
out our partitions so they have
relatively even load po per node in our
system okay so let's go ahead and get to
a conclusion basically geospatial
indexes are one of those Niche
technologies that in my opinion you're
probably not going to come across that
much unless you happen to work on a team
that's working with a lot of map data
but at the same time uh it seems
companies do love to ask questions about
Yelp Uber Tinder for whatever reason and
as a result it seems like the best thing
to do is uh you know just go ahead and
learn about it so I hope this video is
helpful of course eventually we'll end
up doing those problems and uh this
topic will come back up but for now I
hope it is a good introduction anyways
guys enjoy the video I will see you in
the next one